America and we're here under the red
lights of the seventh circle of hell
either that or I'm under the red lights
of twisted metal I haven't played to mr.
Mendelson twisted metal black for the
PlayStation 2 it's literally been years
I just played the new twisted metal
coming out what we did was to capture
the flag kind of mode you had to go and
get their leader and bring them back to
there are few modes in here it's not
just you know an all-out kill everyone
kind of thing and I like that you gotta
have I mean in this day and age you
gotta roll the times and the time say
that you need a few different modes of
the game like this and I'm glad they got
that but in this game you only play the
sweet tooth that you can pick between a
bunch of different vehicles the first
one I did was a helicopter into how and
a lot of games like this you picked a
helicopter and you're like I can't
control this helicopter free [ __ ] this
is like the worst helicopter control
ever you know why because it's so real
do you need like a seven year degree to
fly it this was not like that a couple
analog controllers and you're going
right into battle you're wasting things
I mean it's just metal on metal Rockets
on Rockets guns on guns and then after I
died the first time to pick the
motorcycle when you are the motorcycle
in the new twisted metal you feel just
like machete dude you like go off a ramp
you go down just was just like wasted
that I'm telling you twisted metals back
now like mortal combat with faxes last
year
hey
and in the world with the sony booth i
got a chance to play resistance 3 and i
played it with the gun setup but the
playstation move and I was like yeah
sure we'll try that out we'll see how
badass I am now what kind of give me cuz
this [ __ ] your guys like always aiming
at the ground and whatnot look I
understand you want to be like Nintendo
you want your little wii motion
controller we get that but stop doing
this [ __ ] you know why because unless
the goal in resistance 3 is to shoot
cockroaches on the grounds the world's
losing
but resistance 3 they really stepped it
up from the other resistance games the
graphics are better the game plays
better I mean give me the controller but
I'm just saying it's pretty fun but in
the world of resistance 3 vs Gears of
War 3 i'm a playstation guy you guys
know that but Gears of War 3 is just a
better game I'm sorry Sony and of course
you cannot hit the sony booth without
hitting up in charter 3 now when Troy 23
here is actually kind of a funny thing
for me because the playable demo that
you get to play it's the multiplayer
I've already played the multiplayer beta
if you want to check out my review of
the multiplayer beta check out the
annotation right there on the corner I'm
just saying but I've already played it
it might have seemed a little more
polish but it was nothing new to me but
in terms of the presentation the
producer of the game was actually
playing an action segment it's the scene
you know the trailer or a big old cargo
container humble smacks him in the face
it's that segment right there and if you
were excited before you got to see this
presentation because no one does a
playable action sequence like a [ __ ]
it's just the way it is it's on parallel
you can take any game here and no one
does inflatable action sequence like
uncharted and charter three is going to
rule I wish I had a better playable demo
for me but in terms of what I saw the
game is going to rock